et pour en parler justement sur ce
plateau linda zarrou rares présidente de
l'association des victimes et rescapés
de la rue de trévise bonsoir linda zawa
remercie d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france et d'avoir accepté donc de
nous avoir apporté votre témoignage la
mairie de paris qui annonce donc une
alimentation de 20 millions d'euros du
fonds d'indemnisation des victimes de
l'explosion votre état d'esprit est
votre réaction ce soir
notre première réaction enfin la
première pensée va bien sûr à toutes les
victimes à inès inès qui s'est battu
depuis depuis son lit d'hôpital elle a
subi sa 41e opération le 24 septembre il
faut savoir que quand elle est rentrée à
l'hôpital elle avait dans la tête que
elle a reçu un courrier de la sécurité
sociale qui mettait fin à ses droits
donc forcément une pensée pour pour inès
qui a interpellé madame hidalgo dès le
25 septembre
et qui au final on a eu cette réponse de
madame hidalgo grâce effectivement à
l'interpellation thinès maintenant c'est
33 mois 33 moins de 2 de souffrance
rentrer mode combat de calvaire trente
trois mois où il a fallu interpellé la
mairie de paris l'elysée où il a fallu
interpeller tout le monde donc certes où
il ya 20 millions d'euros maintenant
on a rendez-vous demain matin demain
matin avec emmanuelle grégoire à
emmanuel grégoire pardon à la mairie de
paris
attendons de voir comment va s'organiser
tout ça il ressent du scepticisme de
votre part il ya quand même une forme de
soulagement même si on entend que le
combat était de long ce n'a pas été
aisée mais y est il ya une forme de
soulagement aujourd'hui dans dans le
camp des victimes il ya une forme de
soulagement oui de l'entendre c'est un
soulagement d'être pris en compte enfin
pour un accident collectif de se dire
que on est enfin on va être enfin
reconnue en tant que victime ce statut
de victime tant attendu parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il ya des
souffrances des souffrances au quotidien
des difficultés donc c'est vrai que 33
mois c'est long en trente trois mois ça
malheureusement aggraver la situation
des faits cris des blessés des victimes
grièvement blessées des postes roma qui
sont très lourds s'est aggravée
l'anxiété donc forcément oui on est
soulagé en même temps quand on voit pour
azf que en 30 jours c'est l'accord cadre
a été mis en place quand on voit
pourquoi très vite ses 33 mois certes on
est soulagés mais on porte un poids très
très lourd sur nos épaules sauf que là
manifestement l'adjoint à la mairie de
paris monsieur grégoire dit il n'y a pas
de culpabilité donc il ya des victimes
mais pas de coupable en tout cas selon
la mairie de paris est ce que c'est ça
qui selon vous a rendu justement
difficile le fait qu'ils aient un accord
et cette indemnisation
il n'y a pas de coupable effectivement
puisque l'instruction est en cours donc
il faut laisser le temps à la justice de
faire son travail mais en attendant on
n'a pas le droit de laisser les victimes
comme ça sur le côté est vraiment où
personne ne s'occupe d'elle il ya eu des
besoins et des besoins très très
important il ya des situations
dramatiques
certes oui
chacun essayait de
chacun essayait de se couvrir par par
cette culpabilité disant oui je suis pas
coupable mais en attendant il ya des
victimes qui ont souffert ça vous chante
justement que cet adjoint lise voilà il
ne faut pas que ça présume de la
culpabilité parce qu'il y aura une
enquête qui aura bien une enquête en
cours ça vous chante ce genre de
déclarations bien sûr où c'est le jeu
finalement il se pourrait que la mairie
de paris ne soit pas coupable selon vous
c'est quelque chose qu'on vous envisagez
alors nous que ce soit la mérite pas
requis grdf peu importe le coupable au
final
ce qu'on aurait aimé ce qu'on aurait
voulu c'est que les victimes soient
prises en compte soit prise en charge
dès le 12 janvier 2019 ce qui n'a pas
été le cas
chacun essaye effectivement de la de
d'établir une image en disant je ne suis
pas coupable ce n'est pas nous donc je
n'ai indemnise pas parce que je ne suis
pas coupable mais ce qu'il faut penser
aussi à toutes ces victimes à tous et
c'est ces personnes ces travailleurs qui
étaient présents c'est touristes faut
penser aux orphelins parce qu'il ya eu
les orphelins de laura laura qui est
décédé
les trois orphelins de laura il ya les
orphelins des pompiers qui sont décédés
aussi ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
victimes qui étaient salariés des hôtels
qui ont été grièvement dix handicapés
grièvement blessée devenus handicapés
ont vu les pompiers explosé face à eux
ils ont vu les ponts qui mourir donc
forcément il ya des séquelles
extrêmement grave et au delà de la
culpabilité on aurait aimé voilà
beaucoup plus d'empathie d'attention et
surtout une vraie prise en charge
aujourd'hui il
les critiques sont très sévères envers
la maire de paris anne hidalgo notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux la maire du 9e
arrondissement qui dénoncent elles
clairement un coup d'état médiatique
avec cette aide annoncée évidemment on
est dans la politique là parce que nous
a pas échappé que anne hidalgo et les
candidate à la présidentielle la maire
du 9e n'est certainement pas de son bord
mais est ce que vous vous l'accueillez
de la sorte une forme de deux coups
médiatiques peut-être à sept mois à six
mois de la présidentielle
est ce que madame hidalgo avait le choix
face à inès inès une étudiante en droit
qui a travaillé trois jours qui a
explosé sa vie a complètement explosé
c'est le cas de le dire elle a subi sa
41e opération qu'est ce que madame
hidalgo avait le choix effectivement à
six mois de l'élection présidentielle
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que delphine
bürkli nous a beaucoup accompagné donc
forcément delphine bürkli parle avec un
vécu un vécu avec nous à nos côtés donc
je pense que effectivement il ya
effectivement un coup politique
peut-être mais c'est regrettable
aujourd'hui on déplore on déplore le
fait qu'effectivement
on a été au milieu de tout ce jeu
politique et les victimes n'ont pas leur
place là ce qu'on aurait aimé
effectivement c'est une prise en charge
donc oui je pensais sérieusement oui que
madame hidalgo forcément il ya un jeu
faille un jeu il ya un coup à jouer et
après je ne sais pas si cela va lui
porter préjudice ou pas pour la campagne
présidentielle
aujourd'hui vous attendait autre chose
des autorités quelles qu'elles soient
oui on attend encore puisque ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'a
pas de on ne sait pas qui s'adressaient
aussi c'est la bataille aujourd'hui pour
toutes les démarches administratives
pour les dossiers mdph pour les les
prises en charge de la cpam donc oui ce
qu'on attend c'est qu'effectivement qui
n'ouvrait pris en charge tout le système
de prise en charge des victimes est
complètement à revoir et on a le goût
les cas des cas vraiment concret qui
aujourd'hui 33 mois après ne sont ou ont
toujours les mêmes difficultés donc oui
on attend un calendrier aussi à savoir
emmanuel krieger arts annonce c'est une
indemnisation les indemnisations avant
le la fin de l'année ok qui quoi comment
les victimes grièvement blessées doivent
être prioritaires dans cette
indemnisation puisque l on and off payer
tous les soins etc et quand on pense à
un l'une des victimes qui a perdu son
oeil qui aujourd'hui à des difficultés
pour le remplacement d'une paire de
lunettes parce qu'on a le droit à une
paire de lunettes par an c'est assez
pour tout le monde sauf que lui a
beaucoup plus de difficultés voilà c'est
des sujets sur lesquels les victimes ne
doivent pas s'attarder et ça doit pas
être leur problème merci beaucoup en
tout cas linda zaoura d'être venu
apporter votre témoignage ce soir merci
à vous